[音楽]
[拍手]
今日は
皆さんに
魔法をかけに来ました
あなた方の中にある
呪いの魔王すなわち
解放する
魔法です
魔法ってね
知らないうちにかかってるもんだ
皆さんは
好きなもの好きなことを見つけなさいそう
言われたことがあるかしら
好きなものを見つけるそれはいいことだね
でも
昨日見つけなきゃ
好きなことが見つからないそう悩む人が
増えているという
あなたの周りにもいるかもしれない
あなた自身がそう悩んだことがあるかも
しれない
好きなことって本当はワクワクするはずな
のに
考えるとなぜか苦しくそれっておかしく
ない
[拍手]
言葉は時として何度も刷り込まれるうちに
本来の意味を失ってしまう
そしてそれは
知らず知らず
我々の四方や行動に影響する
これが呪縛です
好きなものって何でしょう
好きなことって何でしょう
これで
外から与えられるものじゃないんです
神様に聞いたって教えてはもらえないどこ
かに転がっててこれください」っていう
ようなもんじゃないんですだって
好きって
[音楽]
感情のことでしょうあなたの中にある感情
です
あなたの中にあるものをありのまま感じる
ことそしてそれを邪魔する呪縛からまずは
解放されること
自分には自爆なんかないよそう思ったとし
ても
もしあなたの周りで
好きなことについて悩む人がいたとする
ならば
前の手はすぐそこまで迫ってきていると
いうことかもしれません
さあ
中学から解き放つ魔法をかけていき
ましょう
[拍手]
はい改めましてみのですこんにちは
ありがとう
ございます私は
文化人です
文化人って一体何なんでしょうね
本人が一番よくわかってないんですけれど
もこれねあの私があまりにも節操なく
いろんなことをやってるもんで何かの
肩書きに限定しちゃうとちょっとイメージ
を違うねっていうことで
皆さんが悩みに悩んでくださいまして今回
はこの肩書きになりました
私は
ボーカリストであり
オリジナルバンドで歌ったり
作詞作曲をしたり
舞台の上で演技をしたり
踊ったり脚本を書いたり演出したりかと
思えば
企業や観光庁に出向いて
プレゼンテーションやコミュニケーション
スキルの
講師をやったりはたまた占い師までやって
おります
占い師としては
某有名
ミステリー雑誌にも
乗ったことがございます
好き放題やってるように見えますか
その通りです
でもね
実は私も以前は自分の好きなことって
あまりよくわかってなかったんですただ
あることに気づいてから
自分の好きに向き合わなきゃいけないなっ
ていうふうに思うようになりました
[拍手]
木と向き合ってどういうことなんか難し
そうで思うかもしれませんでも大丈夫
ちゃんとサインがあるんです
自分の好きに従えてない時ってなんか心が
ザワザワしたりもやもやしたりするんです
よね
皆さんもそういうのを感じたことある方
いるんじゃないかなと思いますでこの
モヤモヤざわざわ
無視してると
必ず良くないことが起きるんです現実に
これが好きに向き合えているかどうかの
サインですこれ
無視し続けるといろんなところでいろんな
形でまるで無意味無関係と思えるような
ところにまで
現れてくるんですよ
かつて私にもそういうサインが私これをね
お知らせ現象って呼んでるんですけど
ほらお知らせ現象がね
色々起きました私の場合具体的に言うと
なんかちょっと転んだだけでね足首の靭帯
裂いちゃったりとかあと5年間で
7回胃腸炎なんて入院したりとかどんだけ
無視し続けてきたんだよって話なんです
けどまあいろいろやってましたねでね当時
はなんかただ運が悪いっていう風に思って
たんですけどこれね今から考えればよく
わかりますやっぱり自分の気持ちを無視し
てたから起きたことなんだなっていうふう
に思うんですよ
それだけじゃありません10代の頃
学生の頃にもこういうことを
起きてましたその時は分かってなかったん
だけど私は不登校や引きこもりを経験して
学校教育からは早々にドロップアウトして
います
今でこそね良い経験したなって思えるん
ですけど当時は本当に辛かった
なんで学校に行けないのかわからない
で親とか先生はもちろん最初
怒りました
学校へ行け学校へ来いて
くるんですどうして学校に行けないの
私はそれに応えようと思いましたでもね
言葉が出てこないんです
代わりに
涙だけがポロポロポロポロ
溢れてくるんです
これが毎日続くんですいや本当震度があっ
たでもねこれもやっぱり自分の好きに
向き合えてなかったからこそ起きたサイン
なんだなっていうふうに思うんですよ
要は
自分の体とか心が必死で知らせてるんです
ねそっちじゃないよ
自分の好きに向き合えてないよう自分の
人生きれてないよっていうふうに
つまり
自分の好きに向き合えてないとそこに従っ
てないと人生にはいろんな不都合が起きて
くるということです
逆にね
自分の好きに従えている時っていうのは
ポジティブなお知らせ現象っていうのも
やってきます
なんかそれでいいんだよって言われてるか
もようにいろんなチャンスとかきっかけが
やってくるんです
でもねただのチャンスじゃないんですね
何か試されているかのようなちょっと怖さ
を伴うようなものだったりするんですそれ
でもやりたいと思ったり
心の奥底にはワクワクが感じられたり
そんなチャンスです
そんな感情感覚に従って私は歩き始めまし
た
ずっと好きだった音楽
歌とか声の活動を始めました
そうするとその一歩がまた新たな機会を
連れてくるそんな風に過ごしているうちに
私はこんなにも
好きなもの
自分の好きにたくさん巡り合うことができ
ました
誰が想像したでしょう
学校どころか外に出るのも怖いって言って
た女の子が
有名雑誌の見開き4ページの部なんて
誰が想像したでしょうただの中卒が一流
企業やお役所に行って
ちゃんと勉強してきた優秀な人たちに物を
教えてるだなんて
誰が想像したでしょうかつての引きこもり
が
国際協力銀行元総裁がお書きになった本に
登場しているなんて
誰が想像したでしょう
気持ちが言葉にできないって泣いてばかり
いたあの子の作った曲が
ラジオで流れる日が来るなんて
そして
ペットで喋ってるなんて
これもねちょっと怖さを伴うチャンスです
よねだからきっと
好きに従えてるんだと思います私はね人生
って
自分の好きに導かれて進んでいく旅みたい
なものだと思ってるんです
でここまでの旅でわかったことは
自分を突き動かすものはいつも自分の心の
奥底にあるものだっていうことです
自分の心の奥底にあるものに
突き動かされて旅に出る
そして
運命に導かれたり時には運命にぶん殴られ
たり
打ちひががれて悩んだり考えたり考えたり
寄り道しながら進んでいけばいいです
そうやって自分の好きから逃げずに
歩いていく間にまたたくさんの好きに
出会って帰ってくればいいんです
誰かがこう言ってくるかもしれません
わざわざ感情をかき乱すようなことする
必要ないじゃないか
物事はシンプルなんだから
悩むことないんだよって
一見正しそうに思うけれど
本当かな
それってどうせ返ってくるんだから
出かける必要ないじゃんって言ってるよう
なもんじゃないですか
どうせ死ぬんだから生まれなくていい
じゃん」って言ってるようなもんです
確かに考えてみれば
物事の道理はシンプルかもしれませんでも
私たちは人間です
人間を複雑にするのも
面白くするのも
感情があるからです
そうじゃなければ人生に何のドラマも
生まれないですよね
よく
考えると
悩むは違うんだよっていう言葉聞きません
かこの時の
考えると悩むて一体何を指してるん
でしょうかおそらく
考えるは建設的で
悩むのは生存性がないそんなイメージだと
思いますだからこそ
悩むのではなくて
考える方が重要だというわけですよね
確かに物事を進めていくためには
建設的に
考えるということは
有効な手段ですでもそこに
感情が絡んできた時にそれは
悩みになるんじゃないでしょうか
つまり
感情を含めて考えるということが
悩むってことなんですよねだからどうか
悩んだり描いたりする自分を責めないで
ください
だって人生の中身ってそっちなんだから
効率よくゴールすることじゃないんだから
この効率化社会では
悩むなんて無駄なこと
悩まない方がいいそんな風に
言われがちですでもねこれも
立派な呪縛の一つなんじゃないかと私を
思ってます
[拍手]
こうして考えてみると
自分をその人生のために
連れて行ってくれるものって何でしょう
[拍手]
よくこんな言葉も聞きませんか
感情に振り回されちゃいけないよってあれ
嘘だからね
[拍手]
感情に振り回されちゃいけないなんて
感情以外に私たちを突き動かすもの
他に何があんの
[拍手]
感情って何よりも私たちを突き動かす
エンジンで何よりも私たちを導いてくれる
コンパスなんです
それを抑えて無視した方がいいなんて嘘に
決まってんでしょそういうことするから
自分は何がしたかったのか自分は何が好き
なのか自分はどう生きたいのか
わかんなくなっちゃうんです
私は
感情に突き動かされて
生きてきました
そしたらこんなにもたくさんの好きに
出会うことができました
ちょっと私の場合ね
多すぎるちょっと多すぎるんですけどでも
さ
好きって1個じゃなくていいよね
でもね私前は
好きなことを一つに絞らなきゃって悩んで
たんです
だけどこれも好きなことをちゃんと言え
なきゃいけないということ同じ呪縛だと
思うんですねどうして絞らなきゃいけない
のどうして言えなきゃいけないのそれは
大人になると銭が絡んでくるからです
仕事にしなきゃって思うからです
ちゃんと絞って言葉にすると
第三者が納得するからです
月は誰のものでもないあなたの感情なのに
[拍手]
現代にはこういう言葉の呪縛がたくさん
ありますでもね
呪縛があるままでは
どんだけ頑張っても物事ってなかなか
うまくいかないんですよねだから私はこう
いう言葉の呪縛できるだけ取り払っていき
たいなと思ってるんです
[拍手]
私あのこんなにどちらかしといて何なん
ですけどまだ言ってないやってることだね
まだまだあるんですそのうちの一つが
コーチングやコンサルだったりするんです
私ねお話ししてるとその人の中にある
呪縛が見えるんですよ
大丈夫でしょ
見た目怪しいんですけど
でねそういう字幕を発見して解き放つそう
いうことをしている様を見て何人もの人が
私を
魔女と
呼んだんです
そうそう私は
魔女でした
[拍手]
今日は
皆さんの中にある
呪いの魔法を
解きに来ました
[拍手]
好きなものが見つからないだからって焦る
ことはない
一つに絞る必要なんてない
感情に振り回されないようにお利口に生き
ていく必要なんてない
[拍手]
感情感覚を大事にする人が増えたらこの
世の中もっと活気あふれると思わない
どうあなたの中の
好きって言葉に
変化はあったかしら
[拍手]
この魔法であなたの好きがもっと純粋に
何にもとらわれなくなりますよ
[拍手]
ありがとう